Please join me in welcoming
Xenia Rubinos to the stage
French be stroll at Dominican chef Italian
restaurant. Bodie question Chinese.
Take Gal. Mexican chef. I'm
ever come on to the end,
the bath or how long has it been
a hippy brown walks your dog.
Brown reason member complaints of his mom.
Brown things.
Your House Berlin takes the trash. Brenton
Eve and wipes you daddy brown cells.
The buttons back on your shirt. Brown
picks the fruit from painting into dirt.
Brown jobs. You Bugs
Brown dives. It texts you.
Brown brings in the gin a
bike when you're relaxing.
Okay,
I want it one it all now. Wow. Oh,
now we build the ghettos and when we
tear them now brown lays brick expound,
builds your wall. Brown tears
them down and built them again.
Brown breaks his back. Brown taste
the facts from gets good curves.
His papers are back.
Brown sits down and Brown,
those frown browns up in a
hospital gown brown has now found,
gets shocked from,
died what he deserve because he fought
[inaudible].
I wanted one it all now.
Oh well now we build the boat.
It take you to town.
We build the good news
and we tear them down.
French beans store with the mannequin.
Chef Italian chef.
It's the Chinese take down Mexican.
Shut
the fridge piece stove with the Dominican.
Shut down your mister [inaudible].
It's a Chinese takeout
Mexican shop. A new, Oh,
I'm never come to that party crossing
batch at that in the other day.
It's a party crossing Newark.
Cut the batch at that in the bay.
It's a party.
Crossman knew chuck that in the day.
It's a party crossing mood.
Cut Back. Chat that in though.
I know.
Give them faith.
Hello?
Hello.
Ooh.
Okay.
I want to
all of them.
Oh No.
It showed that tree fall down
when a tree fall down on it.
Make a sound. No, no where
though and then by the tree.
Fogo down when a tree
don't make the bridge be stolen in
the kitchen. It's a numerous term.
What does the Bodhi quest ship?
It's a Chinese take down mix again,
shut the new America,
but to time though,
it's a French piece of what the Dominican
shut the town. You person about this?
About equal? It's a Chinese
takeout Mexican. New on the brick.
A bunch of back in the bag
party in the Merrick. Kevin? No, no.
It's a party in the mirror.
Did,
did ZIP party cross
batch at that in the bay?
MMM.
Does anybody know what [inaudible] is?
Uh Huh.
Yeah. Why not? What's my shot though?
Uh,
if we can align.
Yeah, but you got the, he said but
shot. Does it look like a Latin dance?
What'd you say is more essential?
More central. It could be,
yeah. It's a dance style is
from the Dominican Republic. Um,
but it's also a music. Um, took it out.
Just put in by chapter in your Google
search engine and find out what it is.
Ask Google. Um, yeah, but
shot, that's what I'm seeing.
But chatter in the back, people are
like, what are you saying? That's,
that's what that song is it.
Hmm.
I haven't plucked man browses
last one of these day.
He gets going to let my mustache crow bag.
Don't know where I'm going.
Only way and know the cliche
is time of feeling on my skin.
I was worried that my papa change
his mother gave him the day he left.
Never saw hurricane,
some Tamma clown and a laugh.
Laugh,
laugh, laugh, laugh.
Yeah.
Does,
yeah.
Does.
Yeah,
we get that loose.
Hey.
Yeah.
No money. Got No money on
no jargon. Okay. No country.
Who Am, I know what you are, but what?
Whoa.
Some town.
Then I laugh. Now I'm
laughing. Clowns. So Tim,
the Queen Stan.
Stan
does feel fat. Weight. You have a fight
when Kevin,
you'll
still
ooh baby.
Can you tell me how far?
Oh, oops. Oh wait.
Oh, Ooh, baby.
We'll see.
Oh,
who's that
help laugh. Clown laughing. So Tom Murphy,
clean state, then the scene.
Now I'm saying, dude, stay in
joke that I tell now.
I'm too
brave.
Feel fairly high
dose. Yeah. Fail fast.
We lose them with too,
man.
Yo Ai though.
Dune born in darkness.
Which juice?
You're brave,
Phil.
You're fine.
We kept the news.
So with Jamal,
Justin,
can you
Ooh,
Ooh, Ooh, Ooh,
Ooh, Ooh, Ooh, Ooh,
Ooh.
[inaudible].
That one was called lockdown.
Um,
and this last one.
Okay.
Um,
it's called just like I,
you guys okay out there and gals
taking the temperature.
You guys all right?
Okay.
Yeah.
Ooh,
Ooh, Ooh, Ooh.
Every sing.
Just what you sell.
Yeah.
Freezing. Google the stuff. You'll see me
bracing
math
every single day.
Live places you'll cook.
Oh,
just
chill.
You.
Ooh. Ooh, Ooh, Ooh,
Ooh, Ooh, Ooh, Ooh,
Ooh,
Ooh.
And freezing. Go home.
Go to work APP. Fill
every single go. Well die.
I prayed to God to lift me.
Ah.
Oh. Just to chill.
I'm just knocked my
father. I'm just like, Yo,
your brother and your mother.
Oh, what does safety.
Oh, it does say though.
It does say t I smile.
I burden you with the same lips.
Oh, it's the same lip. So
it does seem lips. I kiss.
I'm not too with the same idea.
The same eyes old with the same as you.
I've watched you with the
same. Hey. Oh the same.
Has All witness seen hand?
They have fee. I stay out.
Ooh.
Uh Huh.
Oh,
oh.
Just like that.
Yeah.
That was amazing. Thank you. Oh my gosh.
That was so great amount of applause
first that, yeah. Thank you.
So I had,
I had this like
very distinct way. It was going to an
order, I was going to ask you a question,
but I have to start with
something different. Okay.
Because you said something
while you were up here and, um,
I think it was really profound and I
don't know that every performer when they
get on stage gets that
overtaken by their music.
And I wanted to ask you about that because
you, you saying that, um, second laugh,
clown laugh, clap, and he said,
I lose myself in that sometimes
or something to that effect.
So when you're up on stage like
this in your performing and you,
and that feeling overtakes you,
what's going through your mind?
How do you feel about your
music in those moments?
Um, I'm not really
thinking on a, you know,
you can kind of like a rational
level and that's really the problem.
Most of the most, we call
them, we're not a problem.
It's a good time to be a
problem. Um, yeah, I'm, I'm in,
I'm in like a dream state when it's,
when I'm at my best,
I think to be connected to,
you know,
the performance and,
um,
and I'm really grateful anytime that I
get to share my music and perform it and
for that experience of,
you know,
receiving energy from people that I'm
performing for and also giving that energy
out. So when I'm, when I'm in
that cycle and that circle,
um, I, I spin out sometimes
and I'm kind of in dream state,
which can be a problem if,
if like I let my emotions
kind of take over, right?
If I let my adrenaline take over,
I can do things that I could hurt
myself or like jump on people or,
you know, do all kinds of
things that I'm known to do.
But then I don't remember
after, you know, I'm,
I'm not like really present in
that rational sense in that moment.
And then sometimes I'll see a video and
I'll be like, I was dancing like that.
Oh my gosh, I don't even know
how I can do that. I'll be like,
why do my knees hurt?
And I'll look at the video and I'll see
that I was doing like these dead drops,
like doing like pow, like doing
all these crazy things. I'm like,
I don't even remember doing that thing.
I didn't split my pants. But that's,
it happens. Yeah. And you usually
play with the band, right? Yes. Uh,
currently my set up is a
four piece band, so, um,
I am free to,
uh,
sing mostly and um,
I play a little organs in this
current setup. Um, but it's myself,
my drummer,
Marco Bocelli and then a
bass player and a guitar,
keyboards. If things get really out of
control, they can, they usually are.
I let you go there on the back
line. They're holding it down. Yeah.
They're usually just like,
what is she doing today?
That's amazing how we think we all need
to see you at the band. Oh yeah, yeah,
yeah. Come. Yeah, come out.
Yeah. [inaudible] great.
So this is a really exciting time for you.
You're on your second
can album. Your first record was
released in 2013 magic tricks.
Yeah. Yes. Um, and then this album,
which I think is so beautiful,
they're both so beautiful and they're
sonically so different. Um, what,
what is your process when you write music?
What's your inspiration?
Oh, thank you. Um,
well I usually start by improvising,
so I usually start a writing session
first with something that I know,
just whether it's a song that I like or
a song of mine or something that I know
to kind of just warm up. And then,
uh, I usually start improvising, uh,
other with just my voice or on an
instrument, a physical instrument,
like I'm a keyboard or on a,
on the base. In this case,
I wrote a lot of the album on, on base,
which I don't know how to play really.
I just,
I bought a,
I went and I bought a bass because I
was demoing the song and I needed a bass
player to play this lines and nobody
would show up that day. So like, well,
I guess I'm just going to buy one. I'll
return it. I guess I shouldn't say that,
but I'll return it later when I'm done.
But I was having so much fun,
they decided to keep the base.
Um,
and so I ended up writing a
lot of this record on that.
But usually it's just improvising
night and I tried to, um,
just let,
let myself go for a little bit
and then I start to hear some bit,
whether it's a rhythm that I'm
playing or I'm singing were a,
or it's a melody that's happening and
I isolate this, a small bit of that,
and then I repeat it.
So I repeat it a to find out more
about it through repetition. And,
uh, usually when I find
out something about it,
then something else happens that changes.
And that's usually how
an idea starts for me.
So it builds organically yeah. Through,
yeah, through improvisation and right.
And listening.
Do you think the fact,
because the first record was very
synth in Oregon sounding, um,
and the black Terry cat is,
is there's something smoother and
more jazzy, more melodic about it.
Do you think any of that had
to do with the base? It's,
if you just pulling out that base
and beginning to write the record
with it. Definitely, you know, the
writing, a lot of the songs on bass,
you know, influenced the sound of
the album is very based centric.
A lot of the melodies came from,
from playing on that instrument rhythmic.
Um,
the first record was kind of a
piano trio power trio record. Okay.
So it was very minimal. It was bass,
drums and keyboards mostly. Um,
there's not much else
in the sound Palette.
And in this record I expanded
a little bit and uh, I,
I did more vocal stacks like,
and my boy in the vocal arrangements,
I have like these kind of fat vocal
stacks and layering that I hadn't done as
much before.
I used to loop my voice and use my voice.
That's kind of like horns
and different textures was,
which I'm still doing in this record.
But I expanded the sound Palette a little
bit more with more since some guitar.
Um, but I think ultimately what changed
on this album for me was also the music I
was listening to at the time.
Um, so I was really into,
I was discovering a lot of hip hop music
that I didn't, didn't know about. Um,
some groups like slum
village and which was, yeah,
I represented some village
where they were they good clients.
I was a music attorney before I
joined Youtube in 2011 and in 1997,
I think [inaudible] 96 I represented this
artist named some village and I didn't
know that anybody knew slum village.
That was,
yeah,
that was some of j Dilla is a master
masterful work at the beginning.
The producer who was slum village,
um,
I think Jay Dilla produced those tracks
and that a lot of those artist with
donating, his name is Bryce was his
last name. Oh Gosh. I don't remember.
You taught me. You call me on that
one. Really hilarious. Okay. Oh,
they're incredible. Yeah. Um, black
moon. Um, and, and j Dilla. I mean,
uh, discovering sampling, you know, for
the kind of for the first time. I mean,
I knew what sampling was,
but it was just kind of,
I hadn't really been
digging into that music. Um,
I kind of was coming out of a period
where I was discovering punk for the first
time. Um, and I had been
listening to jazz for a while,
but I had kind of been
suppressing some of those, uh,
interests in my music or
I'm not suppressing them.
I was just on another tip and this time
around I was kind of digging into this
music,
going back and listening to Busta rhymes,
who I listened to you as a child as well.
Um, listening to Kendrick Lamars album,
pimp a butterfly was also really
influential for me at the time that I was
finishing this album. That album came
out and I was thinking about, uh,
lyricists,
uh,
rappers and people who use their voice
to tell stories and listening to,
you know,
Kendrick's album and how he sounds like
10 different people on one album and
thinking about different ways to use
your voice. So all of those things, um,
influenced me on this album. I
wanted it to be really beat, driven,
really soul fun and
funky and also kind of on
the vocal performances. Right, right.
Oh, what do you do with your EFL courses?
Incredible. Thanks. So pitch, work,
audit it. Right. I pulled a quote, um,
that pitchfork referred to your music as,
as adept at punk confrontation
as are unbeaten run ons,
which was very interesting to have a
Pumpkin RV and it's the same sentence but
um, and then from, you know,
there's also outside of the,
the sound of the music,
there's really deep messages in,
in the work on this album
and the last one too,
but I wanted to focus on this one
because you, you perform Mexican chef.
What are you trying to convey?
Well, that song Mexican chef just
started out as kind of an observation.
I was walking around running errands and
my neighborhood in Brooklyn and there
were kitchens that were signing up for
the night and they had the back door open
and you could see the kitchen staff like,
you know, cleaning up, setting things up,
prepping. And they were
blasting Bachata and fun shit.
US and Salsa and um, today and
the Google cafeteria, actually,
they were listening to south side, like
on blast. And I was like, what's up?
Who's playing this, all this old school
salsa. And they were like, yeah, we are.
What's up? Um, so that was cool.
But so all of the kitchen staff was,
was listening to this music.
And then in the front of the restaurant,
the wait staff was mostly
white. And uh, the,
the kitchen staff was
mostly Latino and the,
the in the front of the restaurant was
completely different sound palette,
completely different kind
of music playing. And I just
thought that was so funny.
So I started kind of improvising on these,
these words.
I thought it was writing a short
story or like a funny rhyme to myself.
I didn't think anything of it.
And when I got home I just,
I wrote it all down and I thought it
was just kind of making myself laugh.
It was a joke, you know? Yeah.
But then it ended up becoming that
song Mexican chef. Um, so, right.
People are responding to have responded
to it a lot in terms of saying that it's
very political and it's very
social, which, you know, I guess,
I guess it is very social. Um,
but I didn't intend for that.
I didn't set out to write a song like
that. I was kind of just having fun and,
and observing things. But, um, my
mom used to say, when I was a kid,
I always remember her saying this one
thing, um, that, that, uh, you know,
the hands of Brown women welcome you into
the world and clean you and you're an
infant and welcome you in the hospital
and they're the same ones that, that, uh,
kind of take you out of this
world or not take you out, uh,
take care of you when you're
on your way out. Right?
They're the same ones who take care of
you when you're on your way out, you know,
in nursing homes and stuff. My mom
worked in a nursing home. She's at,
she's a registered nurse.
When she first,
I would've heard the first big
jobs in this country. Um, so yeah,
she's talked about the
Labor of the Brown people.
So that's kind of what I'm referring
to in the song is this kind of somewhat
invisible workforce that, you
know, makes our cities function,
especially in a city like New York. But
we're all of these, you know, big, sure.
Metropolitan cities where
we have all of these, uh,
incredible services. Uh,
you can have your laundry,
you could have your clean underwear
delivered to your doorstep if you want to.
You know, it's absurd, but it, you know,
it's, that's the luxuries that we live,
you know,
and these cities and the,
a lot of the times the people who
actually make those services function are
people of color. Um, so
it's kind of a shout out to,
to that workforce.
That's great. I've had the experience,
I've been, I've been in the nursing home.
Mm hmm.
You're referring to.
And I've had the experience of birthing
my own children and had exactly the same
experience and both were beautiful.
Um,
so, so when you think about your, your,
your process and your music and
the meaning, you know, there's,
I think that as an artist,
um,
you have your own perception of your
music and then you have all these external
accolades and critiques of your music
and w are they the same for you?
Do you feel about your music the way
that you read people writing about it in
the way you,
you hear or see people responding to you?
Well,
it's like when you look in the mirror,
the eyes that you see yourself with are
totally different than the eyes that
others see you with. You know, the
lover sees you or a stranger sees you,
you know, so no, it's not
the same. You know, I'm, uh,
sometimes, you know, sometimes there
synergies. Sometimes when I'm performing,
I might be,
I might,
that day I might've been working on
something and channeling something where I
might've been listening to a song like
Eric have I do song or something before I
come on stage. And then after the
show, someone will be like, Oh,
you remind me of Eric about do and I'll
be like, whoa, that's weird. And I'm like,
channel, you know, like,
just because in that day I think that
I was maybe a channeling that or,
or projecting that and through
our transfer of energy,
like somebody received that.
So I think that, you know,
that kind of stuff happens sometimes
where someone will perceive something that
it's a new thought for me that I'm
working on. Yeah. And you know,
and that way we'll agree, but a lot of
times I'm surprised, you know, and it,
and it,
it's fun.
It's fun to see how people perceive
your work sometimes more than others,
you know?
But
how do you want the music
to make people feel?
Yeah.
Um,
well I would like people
to feel joy and to,
okay.
To feel enraptured by my music,
to be,
to feel inspired,
to listen to music or to make
something when listening to my music.
Do you do any other form of art?
Do you write? Do you paint any,
is there any other Larry,
I wish I could,
can you draw us or I can't even draw like
a square or a circle. It's really sad.
Um,
but I do enjoy writing.
I've just been in a fight with
words for like a decade now.
So I'm working something,
I'm working on,
something I was working on on
this album. I wanted to, uh,
work on my lyric writing a little bit.
Um,
because I felt like in my first
album I relied a lot on, um,
kind of figurative language and,
um,
a lot of my lyrics were super open to
interpretation, which they always are.
But I, I was wondering, uh,
what it would be like to approach lyric
writing in a more literal sense. Right.
And I guess one of my big fears
is m two, two big fears is, uh,
talking about things I don't know,
and just adding to the noise of people
just talking about things they don't know
about.
And the second was about being corny or
cheesy with like being so literal that
it's corny right now. And so now I, I
just went for it. And I was, you know,
was literal,
but writing is something I'm really
curious about and interested in.
Right. There are some
artists and songwriters that,
that actually put down the lyrics
first. They create music to it, right?
Or vice versa.
Yeah.
Yeah. In my case, I've always
done it the other way around. My,
the sounds and melodies
and rhythms come first.
And the lyrics have always been last.
But on this record, I was, I was like,
no girl, you go in and you write
the words down. What does that mean?
So I was trying to be more specific.
Right. And you know, it was, it's tough.
I'm the only way I convince myself
a couple of times just being like,
don't worry, you're gonna
throw it away afterwards. Like,
no one will ever see this. So I
had just had to, you know, it's,
it can be petrifying just to be that
specific. And so, and, and now, you know,
we're just always throwing out words
all the time to each other, you know,
on Twitter or whatever. We're just
always like, [inaudible], everything is,
everyone is so entitled
to say whatever they want.
All the time and write it
down, you know, um, and not,
maybe not always think
about it before, but, um,
do you use your social media in,
in promoting your shows or
things like that? You want music?
Yeah, I do. It's complicated.
We have a complicated
relationship even working on it.
The artist that has a
complicated relationship with
social media, um, I, you know,
I, the one is, and you
probably feel this also,
is there's so many different places
to go to reach your fans today.
And you know, I hear sometimes
from artists, will I mind youtube?
And I'm on Twitter and I have Facebook
and I have Instagram and I have snapchat
and I have whatsapp. I, you know,
it's like the litany of different outlets
and where should I go first and where
should I reach my fan? And I think it's
kind of difficult when, you know, um,
and I think some artists will just select
one place to really focus on and build
a fan base. I Dunno. Do
you know, how do you,
well, yeah, I just have
fun, you know? Yeah.
I think ultimately people can tell when
you're not about something in general.
Like if you're playing a song that you
don't believe in or that you don't like
what you're doing, people can
tell. So I think, you know,
audiences are smart and people are smart,
smarter than we give them credit for it.
So I think like trying to
be genuine in all of those
things. So, you know, I might,
I tried by just makes me feel old. I
don't understand what's going on. I'm not,
I can't ever find, I like to trying to
respond. I'm like trying to do the thing.
Um, but, and I can't figure
it out. Um, but yeah,
I just try to have fun and, and figure
out my, my way and not force things.
You know. What's your favorite
song to play? Oof. Uh,
see them, which is a jam
I didn't play today. Um,
but that's kind of like a B side jam from,
from uh, black Terry cat. Okay. And, uh,
it's kind of a choose your own adventure
song except I chose it for you but you,
but uh,
but it kind of,
it's kind of has some similarities
to through composed piece,
which is a piece that you know, would
have, if your sections are lettered,
it would just be a, B, c, d, e, f,
g and it would never, never repeat.
It would just go from
one section together.
So I kind of set out in this structure
of writing this thing that would never
repeat, but then that didn't happen. I
ended up repeating a couple sections,
but it still has this kind of longer
development and all these different
sections and I have so much fun playing
that like too much fun playing that song
live. Um, I need the help of my band
to play it because there's so much,
so many layers going on that, uh, to,
to otherwise I would just be pressing a
button and singing to tracks. Um, but I,
I love playing that song live and
seeing how people are connecting with it
physically is cool too.
When are you playing in the area?
I just
played in the area. Just miss me. Yeah.
I just had my homecoming show. Um,
uh, a couple, like a week ago
or something. I just finished
my first ever headline,
a national tour.
That's fantastic. Yeah. Thanks.
Where did you, where'd you go?
All over the U S I went to Canada.
Um, drove from coast to coast,
went to the south. Amazing. Went
to the middle. I went to the west,
went to the east once of the north.
I watched all the directions
I need to ask performance.
You must have done that in the
middle of there. I did that.
I think the summer they play tape them
an advance. Oh yeah. That was fun.
There was,
must be so much fun.
I was really nervous in the NPR
tiny desk performances. I love them.
I was very nervous, but we got
it. We got through it. Yeah.
It was probably a little nerve
wracking in that space. It is.
Then also, you know, there's, yeah,
it's a lot of heavy music cats in there,
you know, that have played there and that
work there. So it was like, whoa. Yeah.
But we got through it.
Yeah. Um, speaking of heavy music
cats, now I've asked you this question,
but you said that who
would be the one person,
the one musician that you
haven't met yet that, oh,
that would be most inspiring and, and
you know, cause you to write more and,
mm. She told me that one
before. You can think about it.
While I'm going to ask Julie, ask if
anyone in the room has any questions or
anything more you'd like to hear or
that you'd like to share with us?
Nope.
All right.
Um,
so when I was first through
a black Terry cat, um,
I was thinking, okay,
this is a little more political.
Uh,
but the thing that kind of
turned me around on that, uh,
was the song laugh clown,
which you just performed. Um,
so in the first line you talk about how,
you know,
you're letting your eyebrows
grow back in and my mustache,
mustache and your mustache
as well. Yes. Um, and that,
that kind of spun me around because
like
I found that political, but then I
questioned why I found a political,
because in effect,
like as a default state,
your body is a statement
to the rest of society.
And, uh, and that's really, uh,
I think that also applies to some of
some of your other statements like in
Mexican chef that, you know,
this isn't necessarily,
uh, you going out to be
political, but I see that,
you know,
in this society your body is political.
Um,
so could you comment to that at all?
yeah.
Well it is interesting.
Thanks for the quick,
they were great question by the way.
Um,
I think that by virtue
of just being who I am,
looking how I look and where
I come from and being a woman,
a lot of just observing and just
saying what I see or what I've lived is
political. You know, it's
just as simple as that.
But it may not be if someone
else, you know, maybe if
you were to say some of the,
some thing that you saw or
something that you lived,
it may not be perceived as political,
but just by virtue of me
telling you my experience,
it's political maybe because yeah,
there are less people who look like me
in certain contexts and situations that
are expressing their lived
experiences and things that they see.
So, you know, that's one
thing. And I think that, uh,
this album is, this work is really
personal. It's, you know, the, um,
the song laugh clown
at that the beginning,
I'm really talking more
about like personal hygiene
and the passage of time and
how I'm,
you know,
I was also working through
depression and grief and,
um,
and kind of having that,
that the beginning for me personally is,
is about,
I'm just, I'm over it. Like I'm not even
carry, like when I'm looking at myself,
I'm like, Whoa, I didn't pluck my
eyebrows, eyebrows for a month, like,
what's going on? What's the deal? Um,
but it's more about just being
in that kind of state. Um, but I,
but I am also in this album talking
about brown girls and people of Color,
um, Brown boys too. And, um,
you know,
talking about body issues.
I have a song called,
I won't say where I quote a
piece from one of my heroes.
Maybe that's who I would like to
meet. Abby Lincoln, um, vocalist. Um,
she was a contemporary of Billie holiday,
but she's a little bit less well known,
um,
and Abby's work and voices so rich
and so beautiful and has a lot to say,
a lot of commentary about things
that she's lived and seen. Um,
and she wrote an essay
that was published in a,
it was called Negro digest at the time,
I think it might be ebony now. Um,
and it's called who will review the
black woman. And it was talking about,
uh,
how in our society,
the black woman is kind of disposable
and thrown away and not champion and her,
her nose is too wide and her,
you know,
her feet are too flat and her face is
too black and all this kind of thing.
So in this, and I cite some of
that in my song, I won't say,
and I'm dealing with some of these body
image issues and that are universal
regardless of your ethnicity,
you know, but of of um,
feeling like you don't fit in,
you know,
just all that be kind of universal things.
But so ultimately this work
is very personal for me,
um, more even more so than,
than political. But it's the other,
if the others who do the other thing,
it's the others who say that it, you
know, I'm being political but I'm just,
you know, sharing my,
my personal experience.
I don't know if that answers your
question, but it's a couple of thoughts.
Thank you. Yeah, thank you.
Hey. Hi. Um, first I just wanted to say,
this is kind of weird for me because
earlier this week I found out you were
coming and I was just like,
oh shit.
And I got here really early cause I was
like, this place is going to be tagged.
I can't believe she's coming here.
And now I'm just like,
apparently I have to tell
everyone to listen to you
because they haven't already.
Um, but I was wondering two things. Um,
first have you always
lived in Brooklyn or, um,
I guess just wondering about like where
you grew up and how that like influenced
you. Um, thank you. Also wandering,
you're just more of your
musical influences I think.
I don't know if you listened to it,
but I kind of,
I'm reminded of like early Virgina
Specter sometimes with your like vocal.
Yeah,
I see that activity or like,
I dunno. It's, it's nice.
Cool. Thank you. Um, yeah,
tell everybody to listen to me.
It's all good. It's all g net. We're
going to spread the word happy.
Happy to be here. Um, I, I'm
not from Brooklyn originally.
I've lived here in New York City
for 10 years, so I guess that's,
that's a cutoff that makes you the real
New Yorker, right? Like 10 I heard,
I dunno, whatever, but I give it
to New York. You have to like,
do you actually really hardy place?
Like,
if you can make it two years in New York,
I think you are safe to call
yourself a New Yorker. Okay.
I've been living here for 20 well so
you are definitely the real deal too.
So you got me beat two and a bit.
Well,
I'm 24 time flies when
you're time flying life.
Um, yeah, so I'm, I was born
in Hartford, Connecticut,
so there's just two hours north of here,
smack dab in the middle of the,
of the state of Connecticut.
Um,
and I've lived my whole life here
in the northeast of the states.
Um,
and I guess the majority of my life
and Hartford and that is a very,
um, oppressed city, uh,
financially and culturally.
Um,
which is ironic pieces in like one
of the richest states in the country.
But um, there, there's a lot of poverty.
Um,
there's a lot of cultural oppression.
There's not much going on, um,
arts wise, although, you know,
folks are always constantly working
to change that. Um, but, uh,
very racially segregated city,
um,
very large Hispanic community
that lives there. Um,
my mom is from Puerto Rico and my father
was from Cuba and they met in Hartford
of all places. I'm like,
really? I couldn't grow it up.
And when the beautiful Caribbean island,
um, but so that's where they met.
And in the 70s,
there was an effort to recruit,
uh,
laborers for the industries.
In Hartford. There was
a cult, huge Colt, uh,
weapons manufacturing companies, huge, uh,
industries in Hartford. And they
needed people to come and work, um,
probably on the cheap side
in, in, in these factories.
So they actually went to Puerto Rico to
recruit workers and offer them housing.
And I think I have to do more research
and I'm very curious on this topic and I
hope to be able to do it soon.
But I think that was how the
ghettos were built in Hartford.
And I always wondered like,
how did all of these Puerto Ricans,
I ended up here and in this cold place,
you know,
the cold and friendly kind of climate. Um,
and my mom was always like, oh, you know,
it's like somebody's cousin said it was,
there was work there or somebody on.
It's always like somebody, family member
told them, um, to go for work. Uh, but,
but I've recently read,
read that about kind of like this
recruitment effort in the 70s,
which makes sense of why so many Latinos,
but, but that's where I grew up. Um,
and I couldn't wait to leave,
you know,
and I spent a lot of my teenage years,
I guess as many peop many of us do,
like wanting to get away
from, you know, where I was.
My family was great and very supportive
and very loving and came from a very
loving, supportive home. Not Musicians,
no one in my family as a musician,
but music lovers,
they love to dance.
They play music at all
the family functions, um,
as many Caribbean folks do.
So I grew up dancing to satisfy,
I grew up listening to
classical music. My father, uh,
who was the Cuban, my Cuban side. Um,
he grew up listening to the radio,
classical music he discovered
on the radio in Havana. And, uh,
he had a lifelong love of
classical music and for him,
modern music was like
Stravinsky or something.
So he wasn't sure like what
I'm trying to do. But, but uh,
when you started playing music?
Well, I, he took me to the,
like a toy store and there
was a piano in there,
I guess when I was like
four and I supposedly sat
down on the piano and really
couldn't stop playing.
I don't know if it was me who did that
or if it was him because he had always
wanted to be a pianist.
Um,
but in that time it wasn't acceptable
for men in that community to be artists
because it would imply that something
about their sexuality or, um,
it just wasn't an
acceptable career choice.
And Cuba in his,
in his community.
I don't know if that's true for all of
all of when he was in Cuba, not after he,
no, no. Yeah. As a child,
when he was growing up,
maybe it was something
in his household or, um,
his dad was not a classical music fan.
He would say that some music for,
for dead people, like don't play that one.
I'm here or whatever. But, um, so anyway,
my dad says that I couldn't, you
know, stop playing the piano.
So he got me the piano. I was like,
couldn't wait. He's like, well,
she's going to be a pianist or like, she's
going to be an opera singer. And, uh,
but then I, I was like, I really like
Mariah Carey actually. I just want to,
I just want to like, ah, I just want
to do more. I carry songs all day.
And he didn't, he was like, if
you want to be like Maria caddy,
you need to learn how to, you know,
uh, read music. I was like, really?
You sure can. I just not. So,
um, so he encouraged me to,
to,
to choose another instrument aside from
voice to learn also how to read music.
And so I started, you know,
lessons and he, he, uh,
like met people at my school.
He was always into something
trying to encourage me to,
to be musical and met somebody at the
school who was able to fund a scholarship
for me to study privately. And that's
how I learned how to, uh, to read music.
Yeah. And some of my musical
influences, I mean our la,
I grew up listening to classical music.
Ravel is one of my favorites. Um,
it has beautiful piano Sonatas and uh,
hip hop I talked about
earlier, j Dilla. Um,
it was important for me to discover Bjork.
Um, when I was in my twenties, which I,
when I first heard her album
post, I was like, what is,
I don't understand what this is.
I hadn't ever listen to electronic music.
I didn't know what that meant.
I didn't know what she was doing.
It took me like a good year to really kind
of come back and realize the depth of,
you know,
her compositions and her sound world.
And that was really inspiring to me
too. So that's great. Another question.
Hi.
So music is brilliant. One of the main
reasons I ended up moving to New York,
and especially like listening to bootlegs
from places like Arlene's grocery and
places like that or Jeff
Buckley playing at Shinay. Uh,
but a lot of those places
are gone or you know,
do they still exist but they're
in a different location.
And I'm kinda curious what your favorite
places are to play around the city or
to see new music that
you were discovering.
Oh yeah, that's a great question. Um,
there's a new newish to venue in
Brooklyn called C'mon everybody.
Uh, that has a really, uh,
great kind of curatorial program,
a lot of diverse,
uh, groups playing there. It's not one,
it's not specific to one
style or one social scene.
I feels like there's a lot of different
kinds of music coming coming through
there. Um, and it's a new space
and, um, very welcoming space. Um,
it feels like a safe space for people to,
to gather.
So I really liked going there.
Um, it's one of my favorite,
favorite venues to just kind of
hang out at and check out music. Um,
Trans Pecos in Ridgewood is
also a really great venue. Um,
that's run by Todd P, kind
of a famous promoter who, uh,
kind of came up doing a lot of
punk shows and DIY shows. Um, he,
he runs Trans Pecos and also the market
hotel that just recently reopened. Right.
I'm also in Brooklyn. Um, so there
are a lot of great venues, um,
to check out music, uh,
check out music at, um,
I guess one of my favorite spaces that
I've ever played in New York best that I
love the sound of his Bowery ballroom.
I think that room sounds incredible.
And the house engineer, I agree, he's
a legend. Like, you know, such a,
such a pleasure to, to work there.
And, uh, I just, I love that,
the sound of that room a lot.
Thanks.
Sure that it's actually a great question
because I was going to Shanae and
Arlene's and brownies. Um, you know,
it was like there was a scene in,
in the East village and then it moves
further down to Ludlow and then Orleans
opened and Shinay closed and everything
gets kind of kept moving south. And, um,
and then it moved into Brooklyn.
In the 10 years that you've been here,
have you seen a radical shift?
I mean, I spent some in La,
I spend time in Nashville and there's
been a little bit of an exodus,
it feels, um, for musicians and
artists from, from this area. Oh yeah.
Do you sense that? Oh, absolutely.
Yeah, definitely. I mean, uh,
when I moved here 10 years ago,
you know,
the Williamsburg of today has nothing
to do with the Williamsburg of even 10
years ago. And I don't even know
before that, who knows? But, um, yeah,
I used to hang out a lot in
Williamsburg. I had some, my first shows,
they're at this place, um,
that was called Galapagos,
that used to be on north
sixth street right next to,
what is it a now music hall of
Williamsburg. Then they moved to Dumbo.
Um, and then, uh,
there's a big article of them like
moving to Detroit and buying an, uh,
a fabulous, you know, building in
Detroit for, for like $5 or something.
So there's all that. Yeah, that
kind of stuff going down for sure.
And the last 10 years. And
um, lots of great venues,
glass lands on North on. Um, oh Geez.
On Kent mentality,
that whole scene there with glass,
there was another place called
monkey town. That was my hangout. Um,
that place was wild.
It was like this cube room really small.
You can probably feel like 30
people in there maybe or maybe,
I don't believe it was a hundred, I don't
know. But it was all these video walls,
you know, that you were surrounded
by and then these couches and the,
the artists would play in the middle and
they would have like kind of this like
video music sets like Dj sets.
Um,
and like mostly experimental
stuff like late night vibes. Um,
but with such a great space and so many,
so many great venues that have moved on
and don't exist any more. But there are,
there are new new places play.
But of course a lot of a recording
studio is also have, you know,
shut down and moved away. And um,
you know, it's an expensive city.
It's not an ain't cheap. We got all those
services we were talking about earlier.
It's cheap. You know, it's, it's,
it's not cheap to live here so
that it's not conducive to, uh,
folks who are maybe trying something
new and starting new adventures or new
businesses. It can be a little
challenging, um, certainly when,
when real estate is pricey,
when,
when your rent is too damn high. I don't
know if he can say that on here, but,
um, you know, that, that's the vibe for
sure. But there, but there are still,
you know, I, I, I love New York
City. I love living here. I, I, um,
met incredible people and I meet new,
new people working on really
exciting ideas a lot. And
that's what keeps me here.
Yeah. That's great. All right, well,
thank you so much for being with us. Thank
you. Fantastic. Thanks for having me.
Great.